WELCOME MISTER JONES SAWYER.
ALL RIGHT WELL WELCOME EVERYBODY.
TO THE MARCH TWENTY SEVENTH
FIRST ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
AGRICULTURE.
SEEING A QUORUM.
I'D LIKE TO MADAM SECRETARY TO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HI HERE HERE MATHIS THERE MATHIS
HERE A YEAR [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW PRESENTS FLORA.
LARA HERE GRAY IRWIN.
IRWIN HERE JONES SAWYER.
JOHN SO YOU PRESENT LEVINE.
YOUR NAME HERE ROBERT RIVAS
[inaudible]
OUR A QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED.
I WANT TO WELCOME EVERYBODY TO
THIS FIRST -- AGRICULTURE
COMMITTEE OF THE YEAR WE LOOK
FORWARD TO DOING GOOD WORK FOR
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AS WELL
AS THE THE PETS AND PLANTS AND
EVERYTHING IN BETWEEN -- WE
EXPECT THIS YEAR TO BE AS ALWAYS
INTERESTING AND HOPEFULLY NOT
TOO CONTROVERSIAL -- AND I'D
LIKE TO SPEAKING OF
CONTROVERSIAL ASK MISTER -- MY
CO CHAIR BY A VICE CHAIR MISTER
MATHIS IF YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE IN
YOUR OPENING REMARKS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- SO I
JUST WANNA SAY IS I'VE MAKE
SURELY HONORED TO CONTINUE TO
SERVE AS VICE CHAIR OF
AGRICULTURE COMMUNITY.
THE THEY OWN.
MY DISTRICT TULARE COUNTY --
KERN COUNTY YOU YOU KNOW WE LEAD
IN THE NATION AND AND JERRY --
OVER THE TOP.
AT COUNTY IN AMERICA AND YOU
KNOW ACT CULTURES LARGEST
PROVIDER -- IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY WITH ONE AND FIVE JOBS.
DIRECTLY RELATED TO AG SO I JUST
WANT TO REMIND THE COMMITTEE
THAT OUR JOBS DEPEND ON AG
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- SO TO
WELCOME EACH OF YOU AND OUR
FIRST ROLE OF BUSINESS WOULD BE
SO INCLINED IS -- FOR A MOTION
TO PASS THE COMMITTEE RULES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THEIR SECOND [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CAN YOU PLEASE.
WE HAVE A HOST.
AT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
EGGMAN.
HI EGGMAN AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS NO [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
BIGELOW I BIGELOW I FLORA.
FLORA I'D GRAY -- WHEN -- WHEN
NINE JONES SAWYER?
SO HERE I AM LEVINE.
LEVINE I ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS EYES SALAS.
THE RULES ARE ADOPTED WE ALSO
HAVE FOUR ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IF EVERYBODY IS ALRIGHT
WITH THOSE BEING ON IN CONSENT
CALENDAR THERE WOULD BE -- THAT
WOULD BE THE TIME FOR A MOTION.
THE BILL'S BEEN CONSENT CALENDAR
HAS BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED FOR
THE RECORD LET ME READ THAT'S
ITEM ONE AB TWO FIFTY SEVEN BY
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY.
NEED TO COTTON PESTS ABATEMENT
DISTRICTS ITEM THREE AB FOR
NINETEEN FOOD AND AGRICULTURE
INDUSTRY THAT'S A COMMITTEE BILL.
ITEM FIVE THAT IS AB FOR SIXTY
SIX ALSO A COMMITTEE BILL HAVING
TO DO WITH THE OFFICE OF FARM TO
FORK REPORT AN ITEM SEVEN THAT
IS AB.
SIX FIFTY SEVEN EGGMAN
AGRICULTURE COMMERCIAL FEED.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR EGGMAN
HI EGGMAN HI MATHIS HI MATHIS
SITE AGUIAR-CURRY.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW ON AYE FLORA.
LARA I'D GRAY IRWIN -- ONE NIGHT
JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE LEVINE.
THE V. NINE ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I SALAS.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR HAS BEEN
ADOPTED AND I SO HAPPY AS HE
OVER AUTHORS IN THE ROOM -- FOR
STEP COULD HAVE MR ROBERT REAVIS
ON ITEM TO AGRICULTURE AND RULE
PROSPERITY ACT [inaudible] SEVEN
THE BILLS AND MOVED AND SECONDED
WELCOME MISTER REAVIS TO
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MY NEW COLLEAGUES GREAT TO SEE
EVERYBODY -- SO I'M HERE TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
SEVENTEEN THE AGRICULTURE AND
RURAL PROSPERITY ACT.
SO CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC
STANDING.
IN THE WORLD IS NO SECRET.
OUR STATE CURRENTLY HAS THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD AND WE'RE ON THE BRINK OF
BECOMING THE FOURTH LARGEST.
BUT IN RURAL CALIFORNIA WE NEED
REASONABLE LEAVE THAT WERE NOT
BE LEFT BEHIND.
I AND THAT'S BECAUSE THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT IT FEELS LIKE.
PERSISTENT POVERTY HIGH
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES AGING
CRUMBLING INFRASTRUCTURE.
MANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES OFTEN
LACK ACCESS TO THE RESOURCES THE
CAPITAL.
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE -- THAT
WOULD HELP MOVE OUR AGRICULTURAL
ECONOMIES FORWARD.
AND BECOME CONSISTENTLY MORE
PRODUCTIVE.
IN RURAL CALIFORNIA OUR LOCAL
AND REGIONAL ECONOMIES CONSIST
OF A MULTI.
BILLION DOLLAR AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY.
MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED OF THE
COMMODITIES -- OVER A THIRD OF
THE COUNTRY'S VEGETABLES AND TWO
THIRDS OF THE COUNTRY'S FRUITS
AND NUTS ARE GROWN RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
UNFORTUNATELY.
OUR AGRICULTURAL ECONOMIC
FORECAST IN THE STATE IS MIXED.
AND IT DEPENDS HEAVILY ON REGION
AND INDUSTRY.
UNPREDICTABLE WILDFIRES DROUGHT
INCREASES IN PRODUCTION EXPENSES
TIGHTENING LABOR MARKETS ARE ALL
FACTORS AFFECTING THE FUTURE OF
OUR LOCAL AGRICULTURAL ECONOMIES.
AB FOR SEVENTEEN AUTHORIZES AN
APPOINTMENT WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE.
AN EXECUTIVE OFFICE -- A
POSITION THAT IS DEDICATED TO
STUDYING SUPPORTING AND
IMPROVING CALIFORNIA'S RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND AGRICULTURAL
ECONOMIES.
AB FOR SEVENTY AUTHORIZES
APPOINTEE TO PURSUE THE
FOLLOWING FIRST TO WORK TO
FOSTER -- THE COLLABORATIVE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH FEDERAL STATE
AND LOCAL AGENCIES [inaudible]
THE SECOND. TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS FURTHER IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF RURAL
AGRICULTURAL ECONOMY SUCH AS
INCREASING BROADBAND ACCESS.
PROVIDING TECHNICAL RESOURCE AND
REGULATORY COMPLIANCE AND
ADVANCING AG INNOVATION AND
TECHNOLOGY.
AND THIRD TO BUILD A FOUNDATION
FOR FUTURE DATA DRIVEN POLICY
MAKING BY COLLECTING
INVESTIGATING AND REPORTING ON
ECONOMIC DATA RELATED TO OUR
AGRICULTURE.
AND FINALLY AB FOR SEVENTEEN
WOULD REQUIRE CDFA TO PREPARE A
REPORT ON THE ECONOMIC IMPACT OF
THE SUSTAINABLE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT ACT SIGMA.
A RECENTLY PUBLISHED -- PUBLIC
POLICY IS TO TO REPORT THAT WAS
TITLED WATER AND THE FUTURE OF
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
FOUND THAT AS MUCH AS SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND ACRES
COULD BE FOLLOWED AND FIVE POINT --
THREE THE BILLION DOLLARS LOST
IN ANNUAL REVENUE DUE TO SIGNAL.
I HAVE A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
SIGMA'S ANTICIPATED DIRECT AND
INDIRECT ECONOMIC IMPACTS ON
AGRICULTURE ON OUR LOCAL
ECONOMIES.
REGIONAL AND STATEWIDE ECONOMIC
IMPACTS IS CRITICAL -- SO
MANAGER THANK YOU -- I DO HAVE --
SOME FOLKS HERE THAT.
ARE SET TO DO ON THE
PRESENTATION THANK YOU FIFTY
FIRST WITNESSES SUPPORT PLEASE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS TO
A RUSSIAN WITH A CALIFORNIA FARM
HERE I'M NOT SURE I COULD HAVE
SAID IT BETTER MYSELF.
SO AND WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
MYSTERY OF US TO SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL -- AND WE'RE HERE ON
BEHALF OF A LARGE COALITION OF
BUSINESS AGRICULTURAL AND AND
INDUSTRY LEADERS AT WHO ARE
THINK.
NOT TO DOUBLE BELABOR THE POINT
BUT WE RECOGNIZE OUR REAL
COMMUNITIES AND OUR ECONOMY'S
FUNCTION LIKE AN ECOSYSTEM --
AGRICULTURE IS THE CATALYST THE
DRIVER OF THOSE ECONOMICS AND
THEN THEY SUPPORT THE SMALL
BUSINESSES THE BOOKKEEPERS THAT
BUSINESS MANAGERS.
THE LABOR CONTRACTORS THE YEAR
GATORS -- EVERYONE YOU COULD
IMAGINE IN THESE RURAL
COMMUNITIES ARE REALLY DEPENDENT
UPON THE PRODUCTIVITY OF ACT --
AND WHILE I THINK COLLECTIVELY
WE THEN SUPPORT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO FOR THEM TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THOSE ESSENTIAL
PUBLIC SERVICES TO THE RESIDENTS --
WELL THIS SORT OF INTO
INTERDEPENDENCY MAKES US --
MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL IN OUR
ACTIVITIES BENEFICIAL IT ALSO
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE OF THE
ECONOMICS AND THE POPULATION
DENSITIES IN OUR REAL AREAS
MAKES THIS PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE -- WE HAVE JUST THREE
OF US MENTIONED -- INABILITY TO
ACCESS CAPITAL LACK OF TECHNICAL
CAPACITY TO EVEN BEGIN TO BE
COMPETITIVE.
I'M IN THOSE FIELDS AND
SOMETIMES THE PROGRAMS ARE
GEARED TOWARDS THE
AGRICULTURALLY BASED BUSINESSES
THAT ARE WITHIN THESE REGIONS --
SO OUR INTENTION HERE WITH A
BEFORE SEVENTEEN IS. TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE US WITH WHAT WE NEED
TO BE SUCCESSFUL AND THAT'S
THAT'S DATA.
WE DO OUR OWN LEVEL OF DATA
GENERATION BUT WE DON'T THINK
ABOUT IT LOCALLY WE DON'T THINK
ABOUT IT REGIONALLY IN TERMS OF
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPROVEMENT IN THE AGRICULTURAL
SECTOR.
SO WE ARE ASKING FOR A POSITION
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE.
I AM CERTAINLY WE KNOW THAT
THEIR EXISTING STAFF DO AS BEST
AS THEY CAN WITH THE LIMITED
RESOURCES THEY HAVE TO ENGAGE ON
THESE TYPES OF ISSUES BUT WE'D
LIKE TO SEE WITH A DEDICATED
POSITION.
A SORT OF CONCERTED EFFORT TO
LOOK AT THOSE THINGS THAT WE
KNOW ARE PIVOTAL -- FOR OUR
RESILIENCY MEMBERS I HAVE A REAL
COMMUNITIES I WERE ALSO ASKING
A METHOD TO DEMONIZED THE POLICY
BUT TO SAY WE NEED TO BE
ADAPTIVE JUST LIKE WE STUDY
CLIMATE CHANGE TO SEE HOW WE CAN
ADAPT.
WE WANT TO STUDY WITH THOSE
IMPACTS WOULD BE ON INDIRECT
ECONOMIC IMPACTS LIKE.
LAND VALUES AND WHAT THAT MEANS
FOR PROPERTY TAX REVENUE --
CHANGING COMMODITIES IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY INLAND EMPIRE AND
ELSEWHERE -- WE THINK A BEFORE
SEVENTEENTH HELPS US GET THERE
AND WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NEXT PERSON SUPPORT [inaudible]
LEGISLATIVE. FOUR NICE TO SEE.
OKAY ANYBODY ELSE WE CAN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL TODAY.
HELLO JOHN KENNEDY WITH RC RC
THE RURAL COUNTIES WERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WE THINK
IT'S A WAY TO SPUR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND WORLD REGIONS.
AND ALSO A WAY TO BRING
BROADBAND TO AREAS THAT DON'T
HAVE IT AND RURAL CALIFORNIA NOW
URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON CARE EGGMAN AND
MEMBERS TRICIA GERINGER WITH
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING OVER
FIFTEEN THOUSAND FARMERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE REASONS
PREVIOUSLY STATED.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISS EGGMAN
ANTHONY MILLION ON BEHALF OF THE
ALLMAN ALLIANCE CALIFORNIA THE
CALIFORNIA GREEN A FEW
DISSOCIATION.
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
EGG FARMERS CALIFORNIA BEING
SHIPPERS ASSOCIATION.
GROWERS ASSOCIATION WAREHOUSES.
AND SEAT ASSOCIATIONAL SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER ONLY.
GOOD AFTERNOON TASHA NEWMAN --
THE KERN SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYBODY
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
TODAY.
SEEING NONE I WOULD ASK THAT
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
MR MATHIS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR YOU KNOW
THIS IS TRUE THIS IS FEELS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT -- THEY OWN
MOST OF US IN AGNO THE SMALL
BUSINESSES.
ACROSS THE STATE DEPEND ON THE
FINANCIAL SOLVENCY OF BAG --
FROM BOOKKEEPERS FARMWORKERS
QUINN THE MANUFACTURERS --
RETAILERS REAL REAL ESTATE
AGENTS AND YOU YOU NAME IT.
ALL OF THESE OTHER BUSINESSES
DEPEND ON AG BEING THERE AND
BEING A FINANCIALLY SOUND -- AS
WE LOOK AT THINGS COMING UP LIKE
THE SIGMA REGULATIONS AND HOW
THESE THINGS ARE GONNA COME TO A
FACT TALKING ABOUT POSSIBLY
FOLLOWING OVER 30% OF OUR AG
LANDS.
IS REALLY VITAL THAT THIS MOVES
FORWARD AND HIS POSITIONS
CREATED -- YEAH I WANNA MAKE
THIS CLEAR YOU KNOW THIS. TO ME
THIS IS ON A ROLL BILL.
THIS IS A BILL THAT'S ABOUT
SUPPORTING THE COMMUNITIES.
ACROSS STE CALIFORNIA WHICH
SUPPORT THE LARGER CITIES AND
EVERYTHING ELSE I MEAN
EVERYBODY'S INTER DEPENDENT UPON
EACH OTHER -- REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR COURAGE ON MOVING THIS
FORWARD -- IF YOU WOULD MIND I'D
LOVE TO JUMP ON AS A JOINT
AUTHORED WITH YOU TO SHOW BI
PARTISANSHIP ON THIS MOVING
FORWARD ABSOLUTELY I APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS THANK YOU THANK
YOU [inaudible]
NOBODY ELSE [inaudible]
THE I JUST LIKE SEEMS RIVERS AYE
I I LIKE THIS WHERE THIS BILL IS
GOING -- IF I HAD ANY
SUGGESTIONS I WOULD SAY NOT TO
STUDY THE ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF
SIGMA BUT THE UNFUNDED.
AMOUNT FOR THERE'S A LOT OF
DISTRICTS OUT THERE THAT HAVE
GOOD PLANS THAT COULD BE
IMPLEMENTED BUT THEY DON'T HAVE
THE FUNDING TO BE ABL TO
IMPLEMENT SAID PLANS.
AND SO I THINK THAT COULD
PROVIDE A CUSHION OF THE AMOUNT
OF LAND THAT POTENTIALLY HAS TO
BE FOLLOWED BASED ON PEOPLE'S
ABILITY TO PAY FOR THE PLANTS
AND BUT PLANTATION.
OKAY WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSER --
YOU KNOW I DON'T HAVE A CLUE --
I DON'T -- HAVE A CLOSING YOU
KNOW OBVIOUSLY THE COMMENTS ARE
WELL RECEIVED THIS IS -- YOU
KNOW REALLY IMPORTANT BILL NOT
ONLY FOR THE REPORTS TO SAY BUT
FOR THE ENTIRE STATE ECONOMY AND
SO -- I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIX THREE
PLEASE CALLABLE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS EGGMAN HI EGGMAN
NINE MATHIS.
MATHIS I AG YEAR CURRY BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I'D FLORA.
LARA I GRAY -- WHEN -- WHEN I
JONES SAWYER?
JONES SAWYER AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE I ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS SIZE SALAS.
SALAS SIGN.
THE BILL IS OUT THREE THIS.
IS -- WHEN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
TALK ABOUT BEES?
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I
AM PLEASED TO PRESENT AB FORTY
TWO DAYS AND IT DID NOT SPECIFY
THE SAME CHANGE FOR BEE HIVES
RELOCATED WITH IN THE SAME
COUNTY.
THIS ADDRESSES THAT MISSION AND
THIS NOTIFICATION IS CRITICAL
BECAUSE OF PROVIDES LOCAL I.
COMMISSION AT THE LOCAL I.
COMMISSIONER WITH ACCURATE
INFORMATION TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE.
ARE NOT IN THE SAME LOCATION
WHEN THEY ISSUE PESTICIDE USE
PERMITS I WILL AMEND THE BILL IN
THE NEXT MANY TO DELAY THE
IMPLEMENTATION BY -- TWELVE
MONTHS AT THE REQUEST OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BEEKEEPERS
ASSOCIATION WITH NEED.
IN SUPPORT IS MATT SEVERAL
LAYING HALF FROM THE CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONERS.
AND SEALERS ASSOCIATION AND THE
SPONSOR WITH THE SPONSOR OF THE
AB.
FOR FIFTY THANK YOU MUCH.
HE IS A MEMBER OF NON CHAIR
MEMBERS MATS I REALLY KNOW ME
HALF THE CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS AND SEALERS
ASSOCIATION -- THE SPONSORS OF
THE BILL HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS WERE HAPPY TO ACCEPT
THE IN THEM ANSWER AS REQUESTED
BY THE BEEKEEPERS ASSOCIATION TO
ALLOW EVERYBODY TO UNDERSTAND
THE NEW RULES THE ROLLOUT.
IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE UNDERSTAND
AND KNOW WHERE THESE BEES ARE
BEFORE WE ISSUE OUR PESTICIDE
USEA PERMITS TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYBODY SAY SAVING ALL THESE --
STAY SAFE IN CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
DOESN'T MATTER NOT LAYS HOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BEEKEEPERS
ASSOCIATION REALLY APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATIONS IN THE
DISCUSSIONS WE'VE HAD WITH THE
AUTHOR IN THE SPONSORS THE BELL
AND JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE.
WE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO SAY YOU
KNOW THAT WE'D LIKE TO TO DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION -- FOR AB FOR
FIFTY ALONG WITH -- THE
REGISTRATION REQUIREMENTS
PREVIOUSLY AND IMPLEMENTED BY --
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY EIGHT TO GIVE
MORE TIME TO THE BEEKEEPER SUIT
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE PROCESSES
ARE MOVING FORWARD AND AND BE
ABLE TO COMPLY WITH THOSE ROLES
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE PEOPLE SPEAK IN SUPPORT IF
ANY MILLION ON BEHALF OF THE ALL
MY LINES OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANYBODY SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL TODAY.
SEEING NONE I WOULD ASK THE
COMMITTEE IF THEY HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS.
STIR JONES SAWYER -- I WOULD
LIKE TO BE ADDED ON AS A CO
AUTHOR -- I WON MY FIRST SCIENCE
FAIR WRITING A REPORT ON BEES IN
THE FIRST GRADE.
IT WAS ENTITLED TO BE OR NOT TO
BE.
THAT IS THE QUESTION SO I WOULD
LOVE TO BE A CO AUTHOR ON THIS
BILL WOULD LOVE TO HAVE YOU
THANK YOU SOUNDS LIKE THAT WAS
SHAKESPEAREAN TIMES.
THAT'S A LONG TIME AGO.
MR MATHIS I I AM GLAD -- THERE
THERE'S MORE THAN ONE PERSON
THAT WOULD LIKE TO BE A CO
AUTHOR -- AND BE WHERE I'D LOVE
TO JOIN YEARS JOINT ON THIS AS
WELL TO MAKE IT A BI PARTISAN
EFFORT ACROSS [inaudible]
CERTAINLY.
THE MESSAGES ARE GOOD WE TAKE
YOUR COMMON AS A AS A MOTION
MISTER MASSES AS A SECOND.
GREAT ANYBODY ELSE.
ON A FLY ON THIS [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS THE
AND THANK YOU FOR THE BEEKEEPER
SO SHE'S FOR BEING WILLING FOR
THIS I KNOW WHAT'S ONE MORE
HOOPS TO JUMP THROUGH BUT WE
HAVE ENOUGH PROBLEMS CALL ME
COLLAPSE WE DON'T NEED TO MAKE
SPRAYED IN THEIR OWN COUNTIES.
AS WELL WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE THEM.
JUST ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OKAY
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON AB FOR FIFTY IRWIN.
AND THE MOTION IS TO PASTOR
PROCREATION MATHIS OUR SKIS ME
EGGMAN HI.
EGGMAN HIS HOME [inaudible]
THE BILLS ARE MOVING SECONDED.
MR BIGELOW THIS IS AB
[inaudible]
SIX THIRTY FIVE AUTOMOBILE
INSURANCE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX THIRTY FIVE
REGARDING MOBILE EQUIPMENT
INSURANCE FOR FAIRS TODAY WITH
ME AS WE BROWN ON BEHALF OF THE
SPONSOR.
THIS MAJOR THE WESTERN FAIRS
ASSOCIATION I HOPE YOU'LL ALLOW
HIM A MOMENT TO SPEAK AND FULL
FLOWS OF WE MAKE THIS VERY SHORT.
FOR MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF
OF WESTERN FAIRS ASSOCIATION A
CURRENTLY THE FAIRS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA ARE PART OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES.
SELF INSURANCE PROGRAM -- THAT'S
NOT REALLY THE TYPICAL TYPE OF
INSURANCE THAT YOU THINK OF OF
AND SO WHEN THERE IS AN ISSUE
FOR EXAMPLE THERE WAS A FATALITY
ACCIDENT A COUPLE YEARS AGO
INVOLVING A PIECE OF EQUIPMENT
ON HIGHWAY -- WIN THOSE CASES
SETTLE -- THAT SETTLEMENT IS
THEN DISPERSED OUT TO ALL FAIRS
ON A PROPORTIONAL BASIS SO WE
HAVE SOME FAIRS THAT LAST YEAR
SAW AN INSURANCE -- THEIR COST
OF THEIR INSURANCE AROUND SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS THIS YEAR IT'S
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS AND SO YOU
CAN JUST.
UNDERSTAND HOW THE SWINGS IN
THOSE TYPES OF PREMIUMS -- WOULD
MAKE IT VERY DIFFICULT FOR FAIRS
AT TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES A
WARRANT CONVERSATION FOR THE
DEPARTMENT JOURNAL SERVICES TO
SEE IF THERE'S A WAY THAT WE CAN
BETTER SMOOTH THAT OUT -- THERE
IS THE ALTERNATIVE OF LOOKING AT
IT IS A P. A. LIKE THE
CALIFORNIA FOR SERVICE FORTY
THAT ALREADY DOES OFFER
LIABILITY INSURANCE SO I'M
CERTAIN THAT WE WILL FIND.
A VERY GOOD PATH FORWARD FOR THE
FAIRS I WILL ALLOW THEM TO
BUDGET ACCORDINGLY AND AND SO
TODAY WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR YEARS OF DEDICATION
TO THE MAKE SURE FAIR STAY
SOLVENT -- ANYBODY ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL TODAY
[inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THERE.
IS FAIR BILL.
THIS ORDER CAN TAKE AS A MOTION.
SEC OKAY OKAY ALL RIGHT THE BILL
HAS BEEN.
MOVED AND SECONDED WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER BIGELOW.
TONIGHT.
THEN THAT'S WHICH WE SHALL DO.
SO COULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS EGGMAN AYE EGGMAN
AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS SITE AGUIAR-CURRY.
BIGELOW AYE BIGELOW AYE FLORA.
FLORA I'D GRAY OR WHEN -- WHEN
NIGHT JONES SAWYER?
JONES SAWYER AYE LEVINE ROBERT
RIVAS SALAS [inaudible]
SALAS SIGN.
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR AN ADDITIONAL FIVE MINUTES
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS TO SIGN ON
AND I THINK ALL OF YOU WHO WERE.
PROMPT AND PUNCTUAL WE WERE ABLE
TO TAKE CARE OF THE PEOPLE'S
WORK AND EFFICIENT MANNER.
MORE THAN [inaudible]
FIVE TELL ME [inaudible]
WHAT [inaudible]
YEAH YEAH [inaudible]
YOU [inaudible]
SEE.
YEAH THIS BILL [inaudible]
EXACTLY [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH -- OKAY [inaudible]
LET
.
I SEE SOME ABSENT MEMBERS COMING
IN.
OKAY.
ON OUR FIRST BILL UP WE HAVE.
SEVENTEEN AND THEN THE CURRY.
A YEAR I GRAY.
ON A. B. FOR FIFTY EIGHT YEAR
CURRY.
A YEAR CURRY I AGREE LEVINE.
LEVINE I I'M EIGHTY SIX THIRTY
FIVE EIGHT HERE CURRY.
A GEAR CURRY I GRAY LEVINE.
LIVING I. N. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR A YEAR CURRY.
A GEAR CURRY I AGREE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
AND THE PEOPLE THAT.
AND THE MEETING IS ADJOURNED